- Welcome back, everybody.
I'm here with Kali Reis.
Give it up!
(audience cheering and clapping)
So, it is the countdown
to the Paris Olympics
and my next guest
is one of the most
anticipated athletes to watch.
She is a two-time Olympic gold medalist,
and current world record holder
in the 400 meter hurdles.
Despite her success, though,
she has struggled with
anxiety and insecurity,
something she writes
about in her new book,
"Far Beyond Gold: Running
From Fear to Faith."
Everybody, please welcome
Sydney McLaughlin-Levrone.
(audience cheering and clapping)
(audience cheering and clapping continues)
Hello!
- Hi.
- Meet another exceptional athlete.
And then, meet another
exceptional athlete.
No, I'm just kidding.
- Amazing.
- I was saying this show
is making me inferior as a human.
I was like, "Wow,
everyone, athletic today."
We need to set this up.
So Sydney is the first
woman to break 52 seconds
in the 400 meter hurdles.
(audience cheering and clapping)
She is also the first to break 51 seconds.
In fact, this is crazy, of the
10 fastest times in history,
history, Sydney holds
six of those records.
(audience cheering and clapping)
You're dominating.
Like that's incredible.
- Thank you.
- I would feel like Captain Marvel.
- Oh my gosh.
- Do you feel good about
going into the Olympics?
Do you feel good about where you're at?
- I do.
Listen, the competition
is insane every year,
so you always have to respect
your competitors, obviously.
Feeling good, but the
target is always on my back.
So just getting prepared for that.
- Do you though, 'cause, nothing like you,
but I did grow up in sports,
and I loved that the
coaches were always like,
"Compete against yourself
and your best time."
- Yeah, absolutely.
- [Kelly] So do you
think about that more so?
- Yeah, I mean, I try to run my own race.
Worry about my 10 hurdles,
worry about my lane.
Yeah, you can't get focused
on what everyone else is doing
'cause everyone has a different process.
And so, for me, every day
it's, "How can I beat myself?"
- Yeah, was Olympic boxing,
is that ever a dream?
It still can be, you do all the things.
- Well, fun fact, I know, fun fact,
women's boxing wasn't in
the Olympics until 2012.
So I went pro in 2008,
and there was no-
- [Kelly] Avenue for that.
- There was no avenue.
So, I could do all the
amateur tournaments,
but financially I couldn't make 'em
so I just decided to go pro.
The day after I decided to go pro,
I heard they were put in
boxing in the Olympics.
But everything happens for a reason,
and I'm glad they have it now,
'cause there's so many opportunities
and I see so many young women
coming up in the amateur ranks
and getting so much experience.
- I didn't know that.
You are giving me all the information.
♪ The more you know ♪
Well, I heard this about you too,
you juggle before meets.
Is this true?
- I do.
- Is this like a meditation thing?
Like a therapeutic thing?
- Yeah, juggling is actually really good,
number one, for like calming you down.
It gives you something else to focus on,
it's really good for
hand-eye coordination,
and it's a really good party trick
that you can just pull
out anywhere, so yeah.
- Yeah, that's an amazingly random thing,
but I love that everybody has their thing.
Did you ever have
anything you'd have to do
like to settle yourself
before going in the ring?
- I like kind of a calm,
funny, chill vibe in the back.
But like I bring my ceremonial ways,
I guess you could say, into the ring.
I usually have traditional
dancers and drummers
bring me out to the ring.
It's an honor to my heritage,
and kind of just that collective energy
to put that healing vibe out.
And it is kind of a cool perspective.
- Yeah, oh, it's very cool.
- Yeah.
- Writing a book, I can't imagine like,
not into the idea personally,
'cause it has to be hard and vulnerable.
- For sure.
- What do you think
was the most challenging
part of writing the book?
- Man, I mean, the point of the book,
I've struggled with fear my whole life,
kind of just my identity,
and being a winner,
and obviously that's not
guaranteed in this life.
And I think I'm very grateful to God
for setting me free from
that by way of Jesus Christ.
- Yeah.
- And my goal with the book
was really just to encourage
readers to seek Him,
and seek that freedom
that is far beyond gold.
And the hardest part I would say
is just being honest with my
past, and my own insecurities,
and things that I maybe didn't do right.
But being able to own that,
and show that with Christ we
are forgiven from those things.
- It is a lot of weight to
put on a 17-year-old kid.
You know, you're saying
you're 17 years old
and, like, I can't even imagine.
Like, even the hormones
that are happening at 17,
you know what I'm saying?
And then, also trying
to do something so huge,
and so much pressure.
That's a lot.
- Absolutely.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Keep juggling.
- Keep juggling.
- Yeah, that's what I say.
I can't wait to juggle at lunch
just to see if I can do it.
Sydney's book, "Far Beyond Gold:
Running From Fear to Faith,"
is available right now, everybody.
Be sure to pick up a copy.
And you can cheer for Sydney
and Team USA this summer.
Watch the Paris Olympics
on NBC and Peacock.
We'll be right back.
(upbeat music)